une personne a allumé une bougie sa
lumière se propage dans toutes les
directions formant une bulle qui grossit
une personne d ne vois là bougies
s'allument et que quand elle reçoit la
lumière c'est à dire quand elle rentre
dans cette bulle
une fois qu'elle a vu là bougies
s'allument et b ne peut plus ressortir
de la bulle
car pour cela il devrait dépasser la
vitesse de la lumière
la surface d'une étoile et mais des
bulles de lumière au cours du temps
mais si l'étoile s'effondre sur elle
même et peut devenir si compact que sa
gravité tire le tissu de l'espace à la
vitesse de la lumière
à un moment sa surface et met alors une
dernière bulle qui tentent de grossir
mais l'espace se comprime ans dans
l'autre sens r reste statique
une fois à l'intérieur impossible de
sortir c'est un trou noir
les trous noirs sont des bulles de
lumière figé par la gravité
[Musique]